[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 hui débat c'est une mesure
phare du gouvernement dit manuel macro
pour booster le pouvoir d'achat des
français
la suppression progressive de la taxe
d'habitation a été votée fin 2017 et
validés par le conseil constitutionnel
au grand dam des élus locaux qui dénonce
une ingérence de l'état dès cet automne
80% des ménages redevable de cet impôt
verront leur contribution diminuer
jusqu'à disparaître en 2020 date à
laquelle le gouvernement s'est engagé à
supprimer cet impôt pour tous sans en
créer de nouveaux est ce une révolution
fiscale ou un simple coup de bluff
électorale quels sont les enjeux de
cette suppression pour débattre de ces
questions j'accueille autour de moi jean
michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines est également élu maire
d'elancourt en face à jacques a
également martin lévriers vous êtes
sénateur des yvelines pour la république
est en marche et également conseiller
municipal à versailles bonsoir à vous
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté cette
invitation alors avant vingt mètres
quelques chiffres en place quatre vents
pour sonder des habitants aujourd'hui
sont assujetties à cet impôt de la taxe
d'habitation dès la rentrée 2010 8
ils vont c'est un taxe va diminuer de
30% que de 65% en 2009 et enfin 200 pour
soi soit dans sa totalité en 2020 selon
le fc eu de sciences po elle établit
notamment que cette taxe d'habitation
coûte en moyenne entre 280 et 350 euros
par an et par ménage
si on prend l'info seule la fourchette
haute ça correspond à à peine 30 euros
par mois et par ménage soit même pas la
moitié du passe navigo
alors première question pour vous
monsieur le sénateur est ce que ça va
vraiment boosté le pouvoir d'achat des
français juste un coup de bluff
électorale d'hier un couple me paraît
mots très forts 350 euros ce n'est pas
rien et d'autres calculs donne jusqu'à
600 euros 3 600 salons bars aux 35 euros
par mois ça n'est pas rien on est
convaincus et si on insiste aussi
lourdement sur ce choix c'est qu'on veut
effectivement redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux gens
réformer aussi et c'était le deuxième
élément d'importance non pas la
fiscalité locale par ce biais là mais un
impôt concret dit fier d'injuste depuis
longtemps et je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord sur ce sujet là c'est un impôt
qui n'a pas été touchée depuis les
années 70 quand on a tenté de le
réformer trois ou quatre fois en 40 ans
sans jamais y parvenir
donc il était temps d'y réfléchir de le
réformer ou de le changer
le choix du président macron était de le
changer d'appareil pourquoi justement
pas leur effort mais parce qu'il était
un réformateur ce que tous les essais
faits ont échoué et donc qui t'a quitte
à recommencer autant casser le jouet et
dire on se met tous autour de la table
on travaille on trouve en trois ans un
impôt dynamique qui permettra aux côtés
des collectivités locales de fonctionner
encore mieux quand ça commence à être
possible s'il ya en même temps le
gouvernement s'engage à ne créer aucun
nouvel impôt ils s'engagent connaît pas
c'est ce qui est déjà le cas cette année
ce qui fait que les claques et
l'économie cette année
de la taxe d'habitation est prise en
charge complètement par l'état sans
impacter les qualités étaient locales
donc le choix est fait à nous d'être
intelligents de trouver de nouvelles
recettes de faire des 10 millions de
charges de diminution de charges par
dans ce qu'on est en train de faire ça
se voit qu'ils permettront de financer
sans un coût supplémentaire c'est mon
engagement aussi sur les cinq ans cette
nouvelle taxe qui est en train de
travailler avec les collectivités
locales de façon positive et
constructive comme toujours et dans le
temps puisque l'objectif on a trois ans
pour le faire et donc il ya un travail
qui est fait qui est piloté par monsieur
bur et richard en concertation avec avec
les élus locaux en particulier la mf
mais aussi le comité des finances
locales qui a déjà fait des propositions
donc voilà un temps que c'est un vrai un
vrai projet un temps casse renault et
grands contribution avec les
collectivités locales
est-ce que tout va bien notamment à ce
sujet la mission phobos écouter j'écoute
mon
mon collègue sénateur bon d'abord eu
vous venez de vous c'est que vous venez
de voter un budget
et on regarde ce budget si vous avez les
moyens de compenser ou pas bon vous
venez de voter un budget déficitaire
vatican ii 84 milliards comment voulez
vous demain honoré
une telle promesse d'abord ça dépend pas
de vous c'est anticonstitutionnel
vous avez des principes comme celle que
vous êtes en train de bafouer le conseil
constitutionnel a validé notamment sa
suppression de la taxe habitation
je veux pas oui mais il ya un principe
consistait le peut-être que vous ne
connaissez pas qu'il est libre gestion
la libre administration des communes bon
si vous avez envie d'enlever un impôt
faites le sur votre périmètre pas sur
celui des collectivités qui ont
l'indépendance un principe
constitutionnel que vous bafouez ce qui
est quand même assez grave je vois pas
moi j'ai des communes que je connais 80%
leur budget cdx professionnelle la taxe
d'habitation
comment comment allez vous enfin comment
d'abord qu'est-ce que ça veut dire 2001
vous aviez dix alors je sais existence
est une promesse électorale où c'est sûr
partie de ce monde politique français
cette classe par land comme on dit qui
ne vient pas du monde de l'entreprise
malheureusement on était un des rares
pays à ça et qui fait des promesses pour
se faire élire alors un coup c'est les
ça va coûter 400 milliards jusqu'à 2020
un autre coup c'est la retraite 60 ans
là c'est la taxe d'habitation la taxe
d'habitation ccc 24 milliards est-ce que
supprimer ces habitations quelque chose
de positif notamment pour les français
après tout alléger les impôts beaucoup
beaucoup de la classe politique disent
qu'il ya beaucoup trop d'impôts en
france ce qui est du ca la mmf les meuf
elle est totalement contre je vais vous
dire ce que monsieur laignel quand même
qui est un qu'il dise président de la
mef qui est de gauche
bon qui dit qui est le président sambi
était local des finances et qui viennent
procure une proposition très intéressant
donc l'or lui viennent dire il parle
d'une réforme bricoler totalement
disproportionnée et fruit d'une grande
improvisation
mais personne n'y a aucun aucun élu n'a
demandé à ce qu'on touche à la taxe
d'habitation
monsieur macron s'est inventé ça comme
lorsqu'il promet aussi que d'ici 2025 y
va denis 300 milliards budget défense
fin mai mais là on voit on n'est pas
contre hambourg
l'entreprise si vous permettez
quand vous venez du monde réel de
l'économie réelle entreprise quand vous
entendez ça sinon on 2 on disait autant
de fantaisie chez communes 18 dont on
parle il n'y a pas très longtemps
ses parents ont fait des promesses et on
remet ça à 2030
vous êtes élu fin et des biens sont et
muscat 2022 rendez compte faire des
promesses comme ça la taxe d'habitation
boîte à sylvain pourquoi 2020 avant
parce que novak et baskets élections je
vous ai laissé parler très très
longuement en quelques mots nous
supprime la taxe d'habitation dont
supprimons le nom nous allons recréer
avec vous un autre impôt un impôt
différents dit nagoshi privé en lien je
le supprime pour les contribuables
je ne supprime pas pour les
collectivités et vous le savez très bien
c'est avec les collectivités les
collectivités seront remboursés à l'euro
près et vous le savez elles ont failli
non alors le tac est en faillite ça
c'est pas tout à fait nous qui l'avons
pris les 2200 milliards je vois mais
puisqu'on parlait des engagements
laisser les filles étaient si vous plaît
mais s'il vous plaît vous avez pas d
engagement du président macro et de son
gouvernement
on est arrivé au mois de mai fait un bon
mois de mai mois de juin on va dire
découvrant un déficit qui allait être
abyssale pour un budget qui est vous le
savez on est d'accord qui aurait dû être
habitable on était dans l' ancien
ministe de l'économie des clubs tenir
éveillés ne les jetez plus mais monsieur
frousse ils ne l'étaient plus vous le
savez très bien donc c'est ça vaut pas
le coup de me couper la parole pour ça
pour ça franchement un budget qui allait
être avec déficit de l'ordre de 3 4 3 3
3 points 4 au mois de juillet annoncé il
va finir à 2,5 donc les énergies mort
lui les engagements la cia finir la sécu
les engagements cd réalité ce sont des
réalités des engagements tri qui ont
parfois fait mal je vais
puis y est sur un sujet qui vous tient à
coeur qui étaient les emplois aidés qui
a fait mal mais on a pris des décisions
fortes qui ont permis d'arriver à un
budget déficitaire certes mais bien
moins déficitaire que prévu l'engagement
pour 2018 ils étaient 2 9
il va être en dessous de 9 et vous ne
savez donc on est dans cette continuité
dans cette ouverture continuité de
revenir vers un équilibre vous parlez de
l'entreprise permettez moi de vous dire
que j'en reviens aussi indirectement
s'était pas l'entreprise pire c'était
monde associatif mais ça fonctionne de
la même façon sauf qui a pas
l'obligation de faire des bénéfices mais
on fait vis des salariés beaucoup de
salariés dans mon cas on sait
parfaitement ce que c'est qu'un bfm un
verre etc
donc on est on est tout à fait dans une
logique de méfiance sur les
investissements projet donc ça je
connais bien à ce moment là et je ne
vais pas prendre le risque
quant à sion servette surtaxe
d'habitation docta taxe d'habitation est
supprimé dans les trois ans qui viennent
sera transformé par un nouvel impôt
dynamique vous savez dans le ce que
propose vous parlez nous soulignait
monsieur lune elle a proposé il ya deux
jours quel qu'il soit assise sur le
foncier bâti sur la part départementale
de la part départementale jean civatte
ils reviennent aux collectivités locales
et qui une compensation ça suffit pas
qu' une compensation sur un un bout de
tva qui serait plus pour compenser
proposition sans même temps dans
l'échangé et parce qu'on fait baisser
les impôts du contribuable on baise les
uns bout du compte rien comme on a
baissé les impôts mais le périmètre la
france c'est tout le monde c'est pas
l'état contre les nouveaux leuven
devient le siège et le problème augmente
il en nous maintenant on en demande à
siéger au billet vert mais vous pouvez
pas dire c'est en augmentation de 1,7
point en dedans compensation on baisse
les charges sociales pour redonner à la
valeur travail un vrai sens que le
salaire est un réseau et là oh là là
vous êtes d'accord avec moi j'en suis
sûr parce que vous savez ce que c'est
qu'une entreprise le salaire c'est
quelque chose de très important le
travail c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
en france même type oublié et donc
revaloriser le sens du travail c'est
important donc ré augmenter les salaires
par le bas de la fiche de paye par le
net à payer c'est essentiel et la csg
laberge
savez très bien que l'aspect d'acier et
compenser largement par cette baisse des
cotisations sociales
donc on peut pas dire que la csg c'est
une augmentation c'est une baisse dans
l'absolu quand on prend l'ensemble des
points
un objet de présenter et la france et
l'ensemble des points c'est pas les
collectivités locales contre l'état
c'est l'état avec les collectivités
est-ce que ça va pas justement avoir un
autre effet pervers c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui la taxe d'habitation plus
il y avait d'habitants plus il y avait
de logements plus la commune
s'enrichissaient sur les fossiles
exemple utilisent exemplaire moi je veux
pas rentrer dans les solutions parce que
je suis pas dans ces commissions et je
vais je vais pas proposer une solution
alors qu'il ya des gens plus
intelligents que moi qui travaille
dessus mais si on est dans cette logique
du foncier bâti qu'est proposé par
monsieur niel qui n'est pas de notre
bord kaki kiala d'être soutenus par par
monsieur fourgous le foncier bâti touche
les constructions en revanche pour les
trois ans qui viennent ou la disparition
de la taxe d'habitation se fait sans
création de ce nouvel impôt
l'état s'est engagé à compenser en
indexant sur les constructions nouvelles
donc il ya pas de pertes pour les
collectivités locales via zéro perte
oui vous augmentez le texte foncière
vous allez augmenter les impôts sur les
propriétaires de belles heures pourquoi
je les augmente passé il allait la
question à ces faits de grains fois à
part montrer là ça permet et leicester
les municipales de 2020 donc que vous
avez soi-disant faisait pas supprimer
vous supprimez pas de toute façon
quelqu'un va payer et ce n'est pas
l'état ou laisser penser que c'est
l'état de l'état n'a pas les moyens de
contrer nous allons veiller à l'état
pense on et venait de voter 84000 peser
100% du pib' et vous avez le record
mondial de renoncer à une marge
on récupère le 11 c'est l'état c'est
nous tous monsieur fourgous c'est nous
tous maintenant ajouter un vrai que
monsieur lapointe récupère ses
différents l'après dans l'univers nous
avons récupéré bien différencier déjà
fort en france si on pour la france
comme une entreprise on a récupéré une
entreprise en faillite ch de camping on
l'a récupéré dans cet état là notre
objectif de tous conclut cinq ans comme
monsieur notre objectif est le même
qu'on était quand même le premier
collaborateur
impressionnant il a été un des
précédents général adjoint s'est pas tu
sais pas tu le premier collaborate with
les candidats étaient peut-être mais
c'était un choc je reviens excusez moi
sur sur cet impôt cet impôt ne fait pas
d'augmentation de l'intérêt de le
supprimer c'est être supprimés à un
point du stade est il normal
et s'il n'y avait mal reçus et type ils
viendront le supprimer
parce que conseiller conjugal ou lundi
mais non on voit alors qu'on voudrait
que je n'aie ajusté voulu garder je m'en
sors je sais je suis moi je sais vous
avez part je sais que vous avez dit
passionné par la campagne des
sénatoriales et donc vous avez dû lire
mon tract de campagne pour les ja toile
où j'ai dit exactement ça que il était
clair que pendant trois ans on ira 80%
et qu'après les 20% seraient remis en
cause et qu'on ferait un truc général un
apogée nerfs je les dis je l'écrive
redécoration solvay a payé
qui paye il suffit de faire des baisses
de charges et pour nous on est en cours
vous regardez on est encore vous avez
pourquoi devant les vendent j'ai porté
2020 parce qu'il faut faire les choses
dans le temps et c'est très bien comme
une machine économique on est
journaliste lady pourquoi 2020 parce que
vous avez une élection municipale
vous savez vous savez quel est le sens
du mot démagogie je vous le dit encore
laure est politique par laquelle on
flatte les masses pour gagner et
exploiter leur adhésion à lons municipal
monsieur flosse est ce que je fais est
juste si j'avais voulu et sa démagogie
si l'état et la démagogie il aurait fait
ça dans trois ans il aura attendait
tranquillement
il le fait dans 3 il le fait en trois
ans et y construit avec vous que nous
votre avis les quantités veulent sont
pas habitués à ça ce que l'état leur
dise travaillons c'est pas son rôle et à
fils s'occupe de ses déficits il
s'occupe de ses problèmes alors ont déjà
chuté les gens 1% de l'un des voiliers
ont fait plus rien c'est la première
année qu'elle ne pesait conseil
départemental des yvelines vous lui avez
enlevé 90% de la dgf nous allécher les
cinquante mille cinquante cinq musées
les zoos lever 75 millions par an moi
j'ai calculé douze communes
total e p 6 et communes 75 millions vous
allez nous retirer par rangée
abc pendant huit ans de façon terrible
et vous le savez aussi bien que moi
c'est la première année qu'elle ne
baisse pas elle va même je pense très
légèrement augmenté monique j'ai vu les
autres un calcul elle va trés gens mais
augmenter donc pour les communes
puissent comparer des communes et la
taxe d'habitation et des impôts
aujourd'hui on rentre dans une logique
de confiance avec l'état et qui est de
nouveau on vous redonne les moyens on
voulait supprime plus comme ça a été
fait pendant huit ans est ce qu'un
problème justement ce n'est pas
justement la position des mains nues
macron par rapport aux collectivités
territoriales ce qui va vers
décentralisation une centralisation et
la réponse quand je vous réponds
le président sarkozy a fait une réforme
de la taxe professionnelle qui a coûté
très cher aux collectivités locales a
commencé a été le premier à commencer
les la baisse de la dgf monsieur
hollande l'abaisser de façon violente je
crois que le moule mot est quand même un
bleu et le 11 milliards le le candidat
fillon voulait l'abaisser de nouveau de
7 milliards et demi sur les cinq ans
donc on est dans une logique où ont
cogné sur les collectivités locales qui
font des efforts d'économies très
important qui était bien plus importante
que l'état aujourd'hui s'inverse
donc le président macron dit quoi je
dois l'état n'a pas été clair et franc
avec les collectivités locales
je veux recréer la confiance donc je
redonne les moyens j'arrête de bca dgf
je demande à la jeune fiancée je ne veux
je vous demande aux grosses
collectivités en particulier de faire
des efforts de limitation d'augmentation
de vos dépenses de limitation
d'augmentation de vos dépenses limitée à
1,2 de vos dépenses habitués alors que
l'état lui s'engage à faire 05 donc les
graves pour une fois alors une fois va
pas non c'est pas fait part pour une
fois faire et l'augmentation des
dépenses de l'état mais je vous parle de
2018 de 2018 ap de 2010 jusqu'à 2022 on
s'est engagé à faire 0,5 par an alors
qu'on demande aux collectivités et on va
le faire
on s'est engagé à faire moins de 8 cette
année on fait moins 2,5 tous les
engagements qui ont été pris et te sont
tenues sont universels c'est nouveau ça
surprend la défense vous promettez 300
enfin en 2000 e en arrestation
comment voulez vous promettre à l'armée
nos soldats qui exposent leurs corps
pour sauver la france comme on peut le
lisez partout but et un autre 18 ses
collègues pour 2030 vous étiez de poser
des faits recèle donc c'est intéressant
c'est un sujet intéressant vous étiez
dans l'entreprise
une autre question porte qu'il va vous
intéresser tous les deux notamment sais
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
les événements voilà vous avez fait
qu'est-ce que ça la chercheure vous
allez fermer les écoles comme les
rythmes scolaires de monsieur hamon qui
est une catastrophe
on est bien utilisé et on est mutualisé
vous êtes au courant on appelait moi
êtes au courant que monsieur hamon ait
pu oui mais c'est monsieur lang est
mieux connu son insu et blanc' 1 aux
cheminées borba ne remettons mais je
suis avec les autorités qui compte on
pourra pas faire les mêmes pas la route
voirie on pourra varier le ccas
aujourd'hui s'engage moi je connais
l'état
j'étais 15 députés la commission des
finances je connais l'état je peux dire
aujourd'hui jouer dans quelle situation
il est d'abord ce n'est pas vous qui
dirigez sait même pas bercy cetc
bruxelles et même de toute façon vous ne
pourrez pas compenser la taxe
d'habitation en fut si vous ne savez pas
si moi je le sais réponse excusez moi en
pleine démagogie show reprend le mot
parce que là c'est vous qui me l'avait
offert tout à l'heure dont je vous le
renvoi avec grand plaisir
dire que parce qu'on fait de la
politique on est obligatoire malhonnête
parce que c'est ce que vous dites ans il
aimait dire exactement vous dit
exactement ça vous dit appartenant à
l'état ont fait des promesses avant on
peut pas les tenir nous on est élu pour
autre chose donc une politique autrement
si l'on reprend l'exemple
excusez moi mais je reviens votre
question le changement de la logique
taxe d'habitation ne fermera aucune
école 9 qu'est ce tu deviendras aucune à
partir de sa vie même pas peu dire
exactement comment vous savez qu'on
prend c'est parce qu'elle me dit
confirmant pas déclasser bien sûr que
c'est à l'euro près donc comme vous
n'allez pas les moyens j'ai les moyens
vous le savez vous le savez très bien le
budget a été voté même si les déficits
et c'est le car le calibre y attend
c'est depuis 40 ans situez vous
vié le président sarkozy à l'époque n'a
pas sauvé la dette parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas les moyens était déjà
déficitaire donc il n'a pas il a pas
lâché ses 100 millions d'euros il a fait
bien donc donc l'état l'état continuera
ses engagements s'est engagée et le fait
la dgf on pourrait pas le faire non plus
en la dgf
elle a été votée vous l'avez vu dans le
dans le budget demandé des touches et la
taxe d'habitation ses dunes jeu je re
comme du président je reconnais je
recommence pourquoi le met ne va pas
surtout dangereux comment vous
m'entendez pas je vais vous parler avoue
je pourrais peut-être que vous entendrez
mieux on a supprimé mais j'ai dû
habitations nazisme et que d'éclairer la
taxe d'habitation parce qu'on a
considéré que c'était un impôt injuste
est il normal que pour un appartement de
la même taille on paye qu'à cinq fois
plus cher à sarcelles qu'à paris centre
est ce que c'est normal sachant qu a
priori les gens qui habitent à paris
centre gagner beaucoup mieux donc
c'était ça leur servira faut bien servi
et impôts c'est un g20
je continue t s'est jetée taxi ce que
subissent pas les machines non non et
non c'est nadal est pas touché 1,1 paul
la touche et émotionnellement la touche
et je vous inflige le père inanimé
il est supprimé et il va être
transformée et monsieur laignel et
intelligemment lui rentrer dans une
logique de force de proposition parce
qu'il vient des bas côtés c'était ya
deux jours j'ai peut-être un peu plus
d'amour ce que va nous sauver
c'était il ya deux jours j'ai l'article
à côté si vous le vois je pourrais bien
placé je l'avais apporter je voulais
l'offrir est tout à l'heure mais c'est
c'est pourquoi parce que je viens et les
autres de retrouver bien que les normes
ici on verra sur les nuages monsieur
l'énième vous ne trouvez pas que c'est
quand même plus intelligent de
travailler ensemble dans une même
logique que d'être en opposition
là on propose aux collectivités locales
de d'inventer avec l'état cet impôt
d'avoir un impôt dynamique si la cie sur
la tva il devient dynamisme et les
élections locales clients 3 dans les 10
premiers quoi qu'il en soit il y aura
justement une première proposition au
mois d'avril concernant ces travaux pour
2020 mais ce sera la fin de cette
émission irréconciliables oublier crise
de crise de confiance à ce niveau là
cette émission quant à vous je vous
invite à voir ou à revoir cette émission
sur notre site internet
tu as une agréable soirée elle semaine
prochaine
[Musique]